what we're looking at here is actually a
year's NIT based code blue computer kit
original CPM was written for the 8080
the said 80s is an extension of the 8080
so it runs all of the 8080 code so this
is actually running one of the original
versions of CPM exactly as it would have
done back in the day right so initially
there's a small little little bootloader
and we select to boot into CPM this is
now money lead CPM the specific BIOS for
this is written by a guy called grants
earned he done need to face it for this
this generic hardware stuff so fantastic
work there but then the B dose and the
the CCP is all original CPM stuff that's
sliding in there so we are back to what
a lot of people YC is a familiar command
prompt we're at the I I disk command
prompt so we can pick up a directory
what are the fantastic things about CPM
was there was such a wealth of software
there was business software things like
WordStar was the first real word
processor that was the killer app for it
there was debase the database program so
if you if you if he was a business
that's a great reason to use CPM because
you don't actually do your accounts on
it and all stuff like that
there was also games all sorts of
utilities and stuff like that but it was
also fairly easy to fight to write your
own programs as long as you know a bit
upset IT assembly code CPM includes the
tools to actually write your assembly
program compile it turn it into an
executable and they just bud there as
your and whatever you need that program
to do well so it's you would use to
write your assembly code these et is the
assembler and that that will actually
create your program from your source
code that you voted Edie Edie
EDD sorry I'm gonna get so so many
comments about that Auto so it's all
kids of course a classic adventure game
regular views
we run Zork or a version of Zork on the
pdp-11 a few weeks yes
I've followed her to 12 y/o I've got
I've got furthered of what he did but it
all honesty you but I was played about
with it first first of all try to find
my way around the the big white house
and coming across monsters and stuff I
didn't get that much further but it is
exactly the same programming ones on CPM
there's there's a whole wealth of of
tech space adventure games for CPM which
are yeah which were all fantastic if you
like that that kind of thing
there are CPM emulators online or you
could be could download and actually run
CPM on your machine so although
originally CPM was written for the 8080
subsequently that means it well it runs
on these NIT it was also later on ported
over to the the 68000 it also runs on
the 8086 i ad send pc infrastructure as
well as one or two other things i think
there's said 8000 and the couple other
things as well
so yeah there were quite a few other
Dodds nit machines eventually the read
CPM CPM doesn't know or care about
graphics it knows at least to send out
something the way I've got this set up
at the moment this is just a serial
terminal so all this does is send out
serial data but yeah with a suitable
graphics card of the suitable BIOS it
will do pretty good graphics as you'll
see from this that's absolutely horrible
it's ended out all of the PT 100 control
codes for the game there a lot being
interpreted properly by my avoid
requires a graphics card okay so you've
got a different way of looking at it out
of the RC 2014 comes the war s key data
which I've put into a total web you
later
on a UNIX machine so it's it's displayed
exactly what it should be displayed as
opposed to what the quality PI's
displayed so got ourselves a little game
here if I play one player game let's see
how we do all this all the little C
characters that's worried about it so it
was like a familiar layout to me
I'm sure they didn't steal this idea for
any any arcade machines go grab a power
pill would go to eat some monsters all
the fun of joys of Earth ASCII archives
grape Yahoo so what we got here then
this is one of the biggest selling
machines that read CPM it's the the
Illustrated pcw 1512 yeah very popular
in the UK market I don't know that he
done so great outside of the UK it was
sold effectively as a word processor but
it said IP base they bundled it with CPM
so obviously the guys are edge to edge
vote the BIOS to talk to their their
hardware side of things the rest of it
is standard CPM as its booted up one of
the things you can see there it's
running a few very basic CPM commands so
it's setting the default directory it's
copied over pip it's copied over set and
it's copied over stuff via the shadows
is effectively the same kind of thing
because you autoexec.bat and stuff like
that that people for me at least dos
rolled will will be familiar with so
once that's all booted up you can then
do similar things like get a directory
listing see what's odd their syntax
looks familiar actually doesn't it I
mean for those of us used to dos yes
yeah the syntax is very very familiar
it's it's it's almost a combination of
DOS and a little bit of Linux in there
as well I'm sure there's be inspiration
these be both both directions they are
because of the way that CPM work to the
fact that it was so popular
that's why Microsoft ms-dos was a cloud
to look just like it it's a bunch of
smaller learning curve to go up to
ms-dos than what it is to something
completely different
so sometimes he floppies wood dies he
often would make backup copies let's try
this one sounds more hopeful and so
there was this game called Lander which
became the full game's arch